NARRATOR: Human beings have
always generated garbage.
In the battle to keep
the streets clean,
the mechanized garbage
truck is a combat vehicle.
It crushes tons
of trash en route
to deliver it to
landfills, incinerators,
and recycling facilities.
Without it, we'd all be
knee deep in garbage.
Garbage trucks have different
approaches to handling garbage.
Some load from the front,
others from the rear or side.
And some are
entirely mechanized,
like this side-loader truck.
The operator inside the cab
barely needs to lift a finger,
as the hydraulic lift arm
does all the heavy work.
The garbage truck has
come a long way since it
hit the street in 1952.
Production on a modern
side-loader truck
begins with the welding robot.
The robot fuses
numerous steel supports
to the truck-body floor.
These supports will
allow the truck
to hold up to the
force of tons of trash
being compacted inside.
Meanwhile, down the line, other
parts, like the roof and sides,
take shape in
separate assemblies.
Once they're
complete, they hoist
the large steel parts
into place and assemble
them within a metal framework.
The framework serves as
a guide to piece together
all the parts of the truck box.
Once assembled,
the workers clamp
the parts together to
secure the assembly
as they weld the seams.
The garbage truck body is then
ready for the mechanized parts,
beginning with the hopper.
It's equipped with a
powerful hydraulic compactor
to squeeze as much trash
as possible into the truck.
They fit the hopper snugly to
the front of the truck body
and weld it to it.
Then they lift the
tailgate into position
at the rear of the truck box.
They hinge it to the truck
by sliding heavy-duty steel
pins through brackets.
Once hinged, the
tailgate can swing
up and out of the way to allow
garbage to be discharged.
The driving force for this is
a pair of hydraulic cylinders
attached by brackets
welded to the tailgate
at one end and the
truck body at the other.
With that job done,
these cylinders
can now extend to
lift the tailgate
and retract to close it.
Across the factory floor,
another team assembles
a pair of steel lift arms.
These lift arms are
designed for another kind
of truck, the frontend loader.
It's mainly used to collect
hefty commercial garbage
containers.
In action, these arms
pivot around the truck cab
and extend to the front to
fork up the trash container
and deposit the
contents in the hopper.
Hydraulic cylinders also
power these lift arms.
When the task is complete, the
forks at the end of the arms
fold back out of the way.
Nearby, workers test this
rear-loader garbage truck.
Its tailgate is split into two
hoppers, one for recyclables
and the other for trash.
Hydraulic systems lift them one
at a time or simultaneously.
Collecting garbage
and disposing of it
can be tough on a
truck's paint job.
So they apply an
extra durable finish.
They spray sealer on the
sanded outer surface followed
by two coats of epoxy paint.
After that, they
bake on the layers.
Meanwhile, the truck chassis has
arrived from another factory.
It's a standard size.
So they chop a piece off to size
it for the garbage truck body.
They install bracket
plates at the back
and slide thick pins
through the holes
to join the truck
body to the chassis.
Using a crane, they lift the
automated side loader truck
body onto the modified chassis.
Once it's installed,
they test the compactor.
Dual hydraulic cylinders
push the ejector
blade to the back of the truck.
They test the tailgate,
which has, by now,
but equipped with the
signal lights, mud flaps,
and other parts, and verify that
everything functions properly.
Once a truck passes muster,
it's ready to handle whatever
garbage society throws its way.
And with these automated
garbage trucks,
there's no need for anyone
to strain their back
or get their hands dirty.
Because these robot
arms can handle it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]